kevin, you're completely helpless
[Jeff] Kevin, you are SUCH a disease!
[Kevin] I wish they would all just disappear....
[Dramatic string rising]
[Kate] KEVIN!
[Sinister sounds]
[Kate, distorted] Kevin...
I made my family disappear.
[Megan] Kevin, you're completely helpless.
[Jeff] You are SUCH a disease.
[Frank] You little jerk!
[highly distorted] Completely disappear...
[Kate] You should ask Santa for a new family.
[Knife flings]
[Kate, distorted] KEVIN!!
[Blood squelching]
[Slowed] ...Made my family disappear.
[Echoes]
[Bricks scraping on stone]
[Blood squelching and dripping]
[Ominous music starts]
[Engine rattling]
[Harry] Here it is, Marv..
[Marv] Wow! who knew you could get such a nice place on Airbnb?
-Yeah, she's okay. [chuckles]
The owner said to give him a call when we arrived.
[Beeping]
[Kevin] Yes?
-Hey there, this is Harry with the Airbnb reservation?
Hey, we're just pulling up now, is it still all right if we let ourselves in?
-Yes.
[Ominous music intensifies]
[Harry yawns]
Actually we made pretty good time!
Uhh let's see here..Uh you're downstairs, I'm up, right?
[Marv] D-d-downstairs? [grumbles]
Screw this, I'm going upstairs. I'll sleep on the couch if I have to.
Wish I got a dang hotel..
I hate Airbnb!
AURGH!!
[Screams in pain]
[Flesh tearing and crunching]
[Continues screaming]
[Harry] Ooh, place looks just like the pictures.
[Flame whooses]
[Screams in burning horror]
[Eyes pop apart]
[Grunts]
URGHH!
[Marv gurgling and blood dripping]
[Mark whistles] This is where we're stayin'?
Hah, this is gonna be the best Twin Brothers Convention ever!
[Larry] Sure is! Looks like Harry and Marv already got the party started too!
[Mark] Say, who the hell is that?
[Dramatic strings start]
[Larry] All good parties start in the backdoor, am I right, Mark?!
[Larry tapping on the window] Helloo??
[Mark] Hey, the key's not under the mat!
Ah, it's okay. I can fit through here!
[Mark grunts and grumbles]
[Music intensifies and comes to a stop]
[Inaudible]
W-w-waai-
[ANNIHILATED]
[Larry ] AAAAHH! OH WHAT- MARK WHAT THE HE-
AAAAHHHAHAHGHGH
Don't get scared now.
[Police sirens closing in]
[Tires screeching]
[Police on megaphone] Drop the gun! Come out with your hands up!
We have the place surrounded!
[Police radio] [Unintelligible]
Uhh shots fired..
[Police sirens wailing]
[Police on megaphone] We have the place surrounded!
Drop the gun, and come on out!
[Officer] GO GO GO GO GO
[Jake] Did you like this video?
Good! Cuz we have a whole show, called the 'Corridor Crew' show.
Where we make content like this,
and we go into detail on how we make it, and the fun that we have doing it.
We made a video, for this, that is on that channel.
We also did one called; "Making Marvel Rated R".
So, consider checking them out, people seemed to have a lot of fun.
[Clicks tongue] Thanks for watching.